bonsoir dominique lapointe bonsoir alors
aidez-nous un peu là comment on explique
d'un côté toutes les crains que nous
avons et qui surgit sur le variant il ya
les craintes inflationnistes
il ya une forte hausse des marchés il ya
une hausse de taux qui est attendu en
2022 aidez nous à comprendre ce qui se
passe
pour la réaction des marchés en fait si
on regarde seulement aujourd'hui c'est
sûr que ça te portent à confusion mais
essentiellement ni venue confirmer ce
qu'on avait déjà fait dans le marché
financier donc c'est pour ça que la
raison était assez neutre aujourd'hui
les marchés boursiers comme depuis
plusieurs mois même que crée année on va
mettre l'emphase sur les nouvelles sont
plus positifs
s'attendre et donc ont réagi
positivement puis on pense que ce sera
pas nécessairement acheter pour ralentir
l'économie de manière substantielle
marché obligataire s'est un peu plus
nuancé c'est à dire qu'on veut on a
continué dans la platine ans de la
courbe de rendement se désole taux
d'intérêt à court terme vont monter
assez fortement en anticipant la hausse
du taux directeurs l'an prochain tandis
que les taux d'intérêt à long terme vont
baisser parce qu'on anticipe la
ralentissement économique qui va être
causée par la hausse des taux directeurs
ok quel est l'impact économique attendue
du variant au micro
en fait leur arrière micron été amenés
comme une vulnérabilité ou un risque
tant la banque du canada plus tôt cette
semaine que la réserve fédérale
aujourd'hui selon nous on est plus qu au
niveau du risque au niveau de la
vulnérabilité et c'est un facteur qui
vont ralentir l'économie on observe déjà
les frontières se ferment il ya des
restitutions économique assez sévère qui
sont bien posées en europe si vous
l'avez mentionné en introduction
beaucoup d'annulations dans tous les
secteurs du service cet hiver au canada
donc à ce moment l'heure l'effet qu'on
anticipe ainsi que les facteurs qui
poussent à la hausse l'inflation depuis
un an par exemple on consomme beaucoup
plus de bien que le service parce que
les services sont pas disponibles bon ça
va durer plus longtemps en 2022 compensé
donc l'inflation malheureusement vont
continuer pendant plus longtemps qu'on
pense et ressent quand elles vont monter
les taux plus rapidement pour venir
contrer cette population donc l'eau
micro un effet inflationniste
c'est ce que vous dites
indirectement c'est à dire que j'ai
parlé de la consommation quitterait dit
optionnel ça va continuer par la plus
longtemps parce qu'on peut pas faire de
tous risques on va des restrictions
peut-être dans les commerces même chose
lorsqu'on a les fermetures des phrases
structure maritime importante on a le
jeu encore cette semaine en chine dès
qu'on a un meilleur coup de corne au
virus on ferme le pas
ça ralentit le commerce mondial ce qui
cause exactement les relations alors
parlons des banques centrales
que va faire la réserve fédérale à la
lumière de ce que je vais pas vous le
dis aujourd'hui que va faire la banque
du canada d'abord la réserve fédérale
pour la réserve fédérale on est un peu
dans un mode de rattrapage pendant une
bonne partie de l'année on hésité à
parler de hausses de taux dans la fois
qu'on avait fait des projections à la
réserve fédérale on n'avait pas prévu de
doubler le rythme et en plus les membres
de la réserve fédérale entre ces trois
hausses de taux l'an prochain par contre
il faut se dire qu'ils considèrent au
micro seulement comme
dans un contexte où l'économie ralentit
à partir de quand
ça pourrait être dès le mois de mars ou
avril quand on sait qu ils ont suggéré
de compléter le programme d'achat
d'actifs c'est quelque chose qui a déjà
été fait à la banque du canada compléter
le programme d'achat d'actifs donc une
fois que ces complète il pourrait
commencer à monter monter les taux donc
ça serait prêté et la banque du canada
c'est un peu la réunion c'est juste que
depuis
les taux d'intérêt montent au canada en
ce moment il n'y a pas de direction très
précise attendre le quart d'heure par
que les caveaux potentiel qui va être
une source d'inflation va se résorber
soit au deuxième trimestre trimestre en
ce moment aujourd'hui monsieur martin va
péter un discours dans lequel il
expliqué la décision pour le
renouvellement du mandat politique
monétaire et dans le discours on a perçu
un peu plus d'urgence d'agir par rapport
à des façons d'être connecté et
confortable et que
demanda adjointe a divisé le
plein-emploi s'appliquait pas
nécessairement dans le contexte où
l'inflation était près de 5% le donc
pour la banque du canada ça pourrait
être aussi tôt que janvier si les
nouvelles et relationniste se poursuivre
pendant les prochains mois donc dès le
mois de janvier on avait on avait parlé
beaucoup du mois d'avril 2022 oui mais
vous comprenez aujourd'hui qu'on
introduit la possibilité d'une hausse de
taux à la banque du canada à partir de
janvier
je crois qui s'est encore en
délibération si on avait un aujourd'hui
j'imagine qu'on attendrait au mois
d'avril étant donné les certitudes aussi
mais c'est possible qu on y est dès le
mois de janvier une fois sinon j'ai dit
dominic lapointe merci c'est très clair
merci bonsoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit